hey guys Matt here from code Tech and
tutorials I know it's been a while and I
just wanted to give you guys a bit of an
update and let you know what's going on
it's a Sunday I'm just chilling in my
office and my robe today and you know
I've been trying to make this video for
like months and I think I'm just going
to wing it and however it comes out I'm
going to give it to you guys I I feel
very bad for not making a video or
anything for so long although I've been
somewhat active in Discord when people
ask questions and there and stuff I
haven't really been uh proactive about
doing anything
or uh get myself out there and I have my
reasons I guess and I'll try to explain
and I don't expect anybody
to accept this as some sort of apology
or anything and it's not that it's not
that at all it's sure I feel bad but
it's mostly because I feel like I've let
people down I don't feel like I've done
anything wrong necessarily and uh well I
guess I'll just get to it so like what
have I've been doing why haven't I been
making videos you might ask and I guess
if you tune into my streams and ask you
probably already know the answer but uh
that that varies and most people
probably don't because no one watches
twitch anymore it's not a very good
platform with way too many ads for no
particular reason uh so it's pretty
annoying to watch anyway so I get it I
get it I I can't watch Twitch either
even if you're my favorite person it's
just such a bad platform with the spammy
ads and not paying its creators and that
kind of stuff anyway that's a whole
another point but yeah so what I've been
I've been doing well I did take a little
bit of a contract job working on a video
game uh so I've been working on that a
lot I don't know how much I'm allowed to
say about it or how much the Creator SL
owner wants me to say so I'm going to
leave it pretty vague for now but I'll
just say I've been spending a good
amount of time doing that and it has
generally taken over my YouTube time uh
for various reasons as well I do like
doing it and
uh as I've kind of mentioned before in
previous
videos YouTube isn't a very stable
income uh unfortunately so I've tried to
make that a little better in some ways
but it's and I guess I've said this
before but I know a lot of you might say
or think that it's like free money or
something which in a way it kind of is
once you get established I think but I'm
not very
established and it basically takes like
hundreds and hundreds of hours of work
sometimes just to make like 10 bucks on
YouTube it's kind of ridiculous so I
kind of just stopped for that reason it
just wasn't really worth my time uh in
that way and maybe that'll improve maybe
it won't I don't know I don't really
care anymore at this point because uh
I'm not exactly hurting for money or
anything like that anymore so it's not
that big of a deal I I just it's
whatever it's it's extra to me at this
point so I'll make videos if I feel like
it and if it's too hard and complicated
I'm just not going to do it um
so yeah there's been that going on so
I've been working on that game working
on my own game just a little bit not a
whole lot and uh mostly just some design
things but it's kind of taken a back
seat too little little bit on the back
burner but also another thing that's
been going on and I haven't really
talked about it on this channel because
it's been a very personal matter but I
think it's time I bring it up since it's
somewhat nearing the end of it anyway
and um it was my mother you know if
you've watched my videos for a long time
you know like one of the first ancient
Archer
Vlogs I mentioned my dad passed away and
that's been years you know 2019 right
before the pandemic basically my dad
passed away and that was kind of hard on
me uh for reasons mostly a lot of
unresolved conflicts with my my dad and
it wasn't wasn't anything that bad my
dad was just kind of a a a crazy person
we'll say so he was hard to get along
with and there were a lot of things that
when he passed just are forever
unresolved and that kind of hurt I
didn't really know what to do about it I
felt like I should have done more when
he was live and stuff so that was that
was that and now several years later um
another tragic event has happened in my
family but you know it's it's an event
that most people go through at one time
or another and losing a parent and then
losing a second parent so that
is that is what happened I lost my
mother to uh breast cancer that uh you
know she's been fighting
for 10 10 some
years and it's
been she passed back in uh August so
it's been a while but for kind of the uh
last year of her life she
had she had moved in with my son and I
and just kind of
helping take care of her and trying to
make the best of things
and it was it was really nice you know
we got to have
some
some what ended up being like you know
last times grandma got the cook [__] I
don't know if I can make this video it's
very it's very hard to talk about it's
still very painful to me um I never
thought it would be like this you know I
never thought it would go down like this
but there was just a lot of things that
happened that I wish I could change now
that it's too late it's that whole
hindsight 2020 thing I guess
but it's not really something I talk
about maybe that's why it's so hard when
I do talk about it cuz I don't talk
about it enough but
uh you know to get to have some my mom
Lo always loved cooking and stuff like
that and to get to be there for for her
and see the The Joy on her face when
everybody tells her the food is
delicious it's it's it's funny it's such
a small thing but it it like it means so
much when it's like the last time or
when you realize it's not going to
happen
again and uh you know cancer sucks
man I to see her in that much pain and
then within the last month or two to to
see her decline
it it crushed
me and I can't
it wasn't just losing her that was
obviously painful but that's in a weird
way you know death is part of life so I
was kind of willing to accept that but
it was more the things around it that
happened um like I have a a brother and
I have a sister and and they just
weren't really there and
that that hurt my mom so
much just
just hear her on her
deathbed I'm sorry I have to put you
guys through this in a way
but it's the truth about what's
happening and I got to talk about it at
some point otherwise I'm never going to
get over it I guess
so anyway to see her on her deathbed
asking about my brother and sister and
me basically having feeling like I have
to lie to my mom or just tell her bad
news on on her final days
was probably the most painful one of the
most painful things I experienced cuz
yeah my my sister's a she kind of went
[Music]
full a well couple years ago or many
years ago no one really knows why she
just kind of went insane and it is what
it is so my mom just wanted to talk to
her one last time and she didn't get to
cuz my sister's a crazy piece of [__]
basically unfortun
and nothing I can do about that
except feel the the pain of it and I
feel like it's my fault for some reason
although I know it's not
but and you know my brother he's all
right but he's kind of been wrapped up
in this marriage that for some reason he
won't leave this crazy abusive chick for
so long and so my brother's basically in
a rabbit hole of hell and uh he doesn't
seem to want to leave it so that's
pretty pain painful and he wasn't really
willing to do hardly anything to help my
mom until it was too late basically so
that that sucked and I feel like it's
basically just me and my son I
have despite having all this great
family or whatever they're they're
they're not really helpful or supportive
even when it matters the most and just
to have
that happen in real life life
just it's so crushing
man and
I I think the only reason I'm pulling
through it all really is well I have my
son and he's pretty he's pretty great
and understanding and someone I can
actually talk to and I like to try to be
the same for him of course
but I don't know it's crazy how age
doesn't really matter so much when
someone
just you know is small smart
or has the right mentality to deal with
things
and and he's kind of like that he's very
cool so and and I also have a lot of
good personal friends you know friends
I've chosen from school and stuff like
that and
then being able to talk to them in a lot
and then I've got some of these this
YouTube deal and stuff and it's it's
something I don't really know what to
think of it since there's kind of a mix
of absolutely bad [__] commenters uh and
and good people you know the The Crazy
Ones are are very few and far between
but boy do they have an impact when they
want to because you know it's that whole
loudest voice minority sometimes just
butts in and I don't know the comments
get really negative sometimes and it's I
don't know how to deal with it really
other than to say gez man get some help
you know but that's I don't want that to
take away from all of you guys that are
awesome and supportive cuz there are are
a lot of you guys and just seeing a lot
of that positivity and a lot of that
willingness to learn and people just
trying to better themselves that's
awesome and that's that's pretty much
what brings me back here to this Channel
and even making this and trying to get
through it but yeah that's that's pretty
much it
that's that's mainly what's been going
on
and it's over now really but it still
hurts hurts as you can tell by like the
tears and the probably the pain in my
voice it's I'm not over it and I don't
know if I'll ever get over it it's just
a really painful
thing and it's changed me in ways that I
can't really even understand yet like
I my aspirations feel like they've
changed
I I don't know what to do I I'm left
with all these things to handle all her
belongings all her estate and that sort
of thing
and and while it's getting handled it's
also like I now just have a house full
of stuff of my mom's uh that ultimately
I need it to go somewhere but it's like
too painful to move you know I I every
time I go to
start you know changing her room into a
different room
I I just just break down basically and I
I can't get very
far at some point I'll get over it and
just do it but just to look at all these
memories of her photo albums
from us kids growing up and then to know
how my brother and sister are now
compared to the great childhood we had
is just so painful like what the heck
happened man you
know what went wrong exactly is it my
fault all these things and
uh I don't want to get too much further
into it but just know that I'm working
on things I'm trying to work through it
I do appreciate you guys
and and everything here it has changed
my life in a lot of ways for the
positive to to do this Channel and to
interact with a lot of you guys so I
just want to say thanks and thanks for
bearing with me and
not giving up on me I guess so that's it
I
uh I've tried to record this video
several other times but when I went to
edit it it was it was just too painful
to for me to edit just to see me like
this so I can only imagine what you guys
feel and that feels very selfish to say
that I can't edit my own videos because
I can't see me like this it sounds weird
but that's the that's the truth I go to
watch and edit it and I'm
just I'm breaking down one minute in
already you know
and so there's been a lot of sadness
this year here basically in my life and
I don't really know what to do about it
other than accept it I don't really talk
about it to people when people ask me
how I'm doing of course I just say I'm
doing okay and I don't know if that's
true or not I guess I'm doing okay in a
lot of ways I am doing
okay um but in a lot of ways emotionally
I'm just kind of destroyed and there's
not really anything to do about it just
it already happened it's
done
and I'm just trying to build off of this
in a way that that works
and doesn't just leave me further
crippled basically and
that's that's
it
so that's basically what's been going on
why has that stopped me from making
videos
exactly I don't I don't exactly know I
just haven't quite had it in me I've
tried a few times and
usually I just abandon the idea because
I can't seem to work through
it but I think we'll get back there
so thanks again and
uh it's weird to release this on like a
new year but I guess the point is with a
new year you're just supposed to change
and do things for the better and that's
what I'm going to try to do I'm going to
try to try to put this behind me uh put
the Comm commemorative things in place
that I need to and move on and hopefully
2024 will be a little better that's it's
funny because there's
really usually when you have a bad year
it's because you messed up or something
but I don't feel like I particularly
messed up things just went real bad you
know and
uh it's been a big year of accepting
that I can't control other people but I
can kind of choose who I'm around
because there's just been a lot of
growing up there's been a lot of
toxicity around me and and it's
not it's not reflected well on me I
don't want to absorb that so it's a it's
a lot
of I really need to decide who I take
influence from and who I allow to
influence my my kid and stuff I I don't
want him
to to go down this wrong path too
because you know it's
been it's been a lot of times where
I feel like I've really gotten myself in
a bad situation through no fault of my
own well I guess it would be my fault
the way I'm going to explain it but
basically it's
because I'll uh I'll have sympathy for
someone or something and and try to help
them and in turn they kind of just bring
in other toxic people and before I know
it I'm surrounded by all these crazies
and strange people and and just people
with awful social skills and stuff and
I'm just like just cringing throughout
the day dealing with these people and
I'm like how did I get to this how did I
get to the daily life where I got to
deal with this crap daily this is not
what I want and I I've just kind of had
to you know part of it went with my my
mom she's way too nice she would help
anyone so she kind of brought in when I
was when she was living with me she was
she kind of brought in a few crazy
people from her church some of them were
very nice and very they're fine but a
couple were like obviously delusional
and had issues and I really just had to
put my foot down and say look these
people cannot come to this house I have
a kid here I'm raising and I don't want
the influence of people who say they see
demons and stuff that's insane and to
have to say that to my mother who didn't
have much longer felt awful like I felt
like I was telling her she can't have
friends over and stuff but I was it
was and I talked to her about it and we
resolved that but there there was an
incident where I basically said hey look
I don't mind if you have people over
obviously and friends and stuff but you
cannot bring delusional people over who
say they see things and are obviously
schizophrenic or
whatever or potentially dangerous you
can't bring people over like that like
and just to realize that I had to say
that to someone that should know
better and that I was raised by this
person and maybe it's part
of whatever past traumas I experienced
was because of that too I don't know
it's it's rough
man but the truth is I've got to break
those bad cycles and and I think that's
what I'm trying to
do and it's it's just really hard to
make these sort of changes when it's
been going on your whole life
and and to realize you have to be mean
to people that are incredibly kind just
because they're you know they don't put
their foot down and they let themselves
get walked on and in turn you get walked
on so you have to say hey look you can't
allow people to walk on you anymore
because now you're affecting others
and and the timing was just so bad man
I I think you guys probably get that by
now but I think I've rambled on long
enough I'm not going to edit this I
can't if I have to sit and edit this and
put music behind and stuff I'm going to
I'm going to break down and not release
it so it is what it
is um positive things going
forward
and I do think things will get
better and uh I'm going to do my best to
get over this this hump and accept what
happened and learn from it
so best wishes to you guys we see you in
the new year take care of yourselves out
there peace